Speaker 1: Hey, we have a voicemail number
and that number is two one nine two.
David, the mask drama will not end.
Yesterday, the egg man called in about masks.
Now we have another caller calling in about
what the egg man said about masks.
Let's take a listen to it together.
Speaker 4: And this is regarding mass, yeah,
and what the man said is pretty much right.
People shouldn't be worried.
As I say, they probably didn't have to.
But in terms of businesses, it's up to the
business.
Yeah, and guess what?
In terms of public transportation, a lot of
the man thinks the subway or busses
Speaker 1: know the eggman lives very rarely.
He's not on any subway.
Speaker 4: But guess what?
We're expecting like the worst flu season
in years.
The only reason it was down was because people
were wearing masks.
That's true.
Fall and winter.
And it's going to be more and more variations
that maybe the flu vaccines can't keep up
with.
So I'm still going to be wearing a mask on
the subways and busses.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I. I feel like for the most
part, everybody's on the same page.
What the Egemen said is true.
CDC says if you're vaccinated, you really
don't need to wear it anywhere.
What this guy says is true, which is we could
be up for a bad flu season.
Flu season was late last year because of all
the mask wearing.
What this guy says is true about businesses
can ask people to wear masks and it may make
sense to put masks back on as we get close
to flu season or on public transit.
And what the Eichmanns daughter said about
I don't want people to look at me and give
me dirty looks because I'm not all of these
things are true.
And I think we've got to get beyond this from
a medical perspective.
If you're vaccinated, it seems you don't really
have to wear a mask anywhere.
But anyone might choose to, for whatever reason
is relevant to them.
That's the it doesn't matter why someone chooses
to wear a mask.
It may be because they misunderstand the science.
It may be because they want to hide their
face.
It may be for whatever other reason.
And I think that that's all fine.
We don't all have to get bent out of shape
about this.
We have a fantastic bonus show for you today.
We are going to preview the Biden Putin meeting,
which we will then cover the press conference
about life later this week.
We will talk about Israel banning the sale
of almost all fur clothing just flat out and
the implications we will also talk about the
average age of vehicles has hit an all time
high.
And cars, trucks and SUVs are getting older
on average as used car prices have been going
up.
This started during the pandemic and it is
continuing all of that and more.
And I will be joined by producer Pat on today's
award winning bonus show, exclusively awards
we've invented.
But we've won all of them.
And I think for a lot of people, that makes
a big difference to sign up at.
Join Pakman Dotcom, a coupon code available,
a better twenty one.
I will see you then or otherwise tomorrow.